When, in 2007 (mistake in the video, I said 2017*), I met my ex French girlfriend in a hostel
in Prague, I would have never imagined that French
would become such an important part of my life.
Hi, my name is Luca from LucaLampariello.doc and today
I would like to talk to you about how I have learned French and the lessons
I have learned on the way. I am positive about it now, but
I didn't know it back then when I started learning French in highschool some 20 years ago -
what counts the most in language learning is not what you do in the class,
but what you do OUTSIDE of it, and that's exactly what I started doing
2 years later, when I started learning French in highschool.
I started watching French TV all the time. I had discovered
that I could actually watch France 2, and not just the spoken language -
I could watch everything with subtitles - Page 888 - I still remember that
and I remember that that gave me a lot of enthusiasm
and I started watching TV-series, documentaries,movies
every single night, and taking notes since I could actually see the words
that I was hearing. That alone completely changed my approach and perspective on learning French
and when you learn a language at school or in a class
in a language school,
you have to know that what you do outside of that class counts for 90 %
of your language learning process. If you work outside, what you do at school
is literally the "icing on the cake".
Si ton tonton tond mon tonton, ton tonton sera tondu" French is a language
where nothing is as it seems. Actually, the spoken language
is quite different from the written language, and that's also why the "dictéee" is considered
an indispensable and compulsory tool to master the French language.
I still remember very well when I used to attend high school that
one of our schoolmates was French - he had moved to Rome with his family.
He spoke perfect French, but he had a really hard time writing it.
It is important to keep in mind that when you learn a language,
you have to learn it holistically, globally, that is,
speaking it well means also to learn to read and write, and the abilities that you develop over the years
are going to mutually reinforce each other. That's a really important point
that you should not forget, and you should make sure you tackle all aspects of a given language
every day or over the course of a week.
As I said at the beginning of the video, when I met my ex French gilfriend,
I would have never imagined that French would become such an important part of my life,
I would have never imagined that I would move to France. This has changed and
broadened my perspective on language learning in general,
because when I used to live in France, I have discovered that
speaking a language is also about knowing the culture, and I have seen .. well, I already knew it,
but I actually witnessed it with my very own eyes - that living there every day
is a different ball game, you learn experience things such when you open the "galette des rois",
the gestures that the French make, cultural references,
things you can or can't do in a given country,
like for example the fact that cutting the salad is a perfectly normal thing to do in Italy, a bit less
in France and all this has given me a brighter perspective on
what it means to learn a foreign language. I say all the time that
learning a language is doable in your own country - but
if you really want to reach a native-like level in your target language - it is important to live that language
and live in a given country, it will give you a global perspective
on that linguistic system because once again, a language is also its culture, and its culture is also
that language, you should never forget that. Ok, we got tot the end of the video
and to wrap up: it is very important
to learn outside of the class, that counts for 90 % of your
learning process. It is very important to learn a given language
in a global way, because a language is like a living organism, and third
it is important - if you want to reach a native-like level in that language - to live
in-country because you are going to witness how people actually live and breathe their own language.
If you want to know more, you can click on the link in the
description box - I have written an extensive article in English on the marvellous French language
which you can also listen to in English.
You are more than welcome to my website and my blog, thanks of listeining
and I'll see you soon here on YouTube!